hi there I'm one of the master model
builders here at Legoland California
we're gonna see some behind-the-scenes
features and some not so
behind-the-scenes features that not
everybody gets to see every day so
allegedly there's a sasquatch up here
I've never seen him well I can't confirm
it at night if it's true I will say if
you look into the woods you might be in
for a big surprise
being a Dodger fan not an Angels fan the
blue team is dumping the Gatorade on the
red team's heads from left to right we
have Beyonce Justin Bieber the Queen of
England and President Barack Obama we're
here in Las Vegas at the Flying Brick
Show we have some vmx bikers and a very
special skateboarder one of the master
model builders built his grandmother in
the middle of the halfpipe on a
skateboard totally shredding so we're
here at the Hollywood Bowl in Southern
California of course we have the
conductor Gustavo Dudamel the actual
conductor of the Hollywood Bowl
Orchestra but I also slipped in some
less than traditional classical
musicians like ebony kissing on piano
way in the back I even have one of my
favorites Teddy Brown the famous
xylophone player but my favorite
favorite mini Lander in this model is me
master model builder and oboe player
Robbie McCarthy has even got my beard
anyone who's been to San Francisco has
been to Pier 39 so a bush man's right
here he's the man holding the bushes now
let's Nagus has lots of awesome shows
but we like to make our own Glen Hendrix
was one of the master model builders who
helped build and design Las Vegas so he
immortalized himself in Lego bricks in
his own special show so behind me is
mainland Washington DC now Washington DC
is known as one of the more haunted
cities in America especially at the
Jefferson Memorial where we have a
headless ghost some model builder or
another keeps moving the ghost around
the Jefferson Memorial so sometimes it's
there and sometimes it's not either that
or it's actually haunted
we've seen everything from San Francisco
to New Orleans in Las Vegas and here in
Washington DC - if you're ever at
Legoland you know stop by and say hi